si monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de permettre de vous
parler d'exprimer nos réactions devant
devant ces textes la première je dirais
c'est que dans cette excitation de
dispositions qui sont certainement
mutilé importante dans le titre 1 est
incertain de dispositions concernant les
mutilations faites aux femmes la
polygamie le mariage forcé toutes sortes
de maux bien connu de notre société
quand même depuis un certain nombre
d'années et auquel on peut être content
que la l'état souhaite occasion nous
sommes contents que l'état ça s'y
attaque pour deux pour de vrai en
quelque sorte si tenté que ça n'ait pas
été fait c'est n'est pas été fait jusque
là en revanche comme j'ai une façon de
l'exprimer dans l'assemblée nationale et
comme les autres représentants des
cultes en france ont pu le dire les
ensemble de dispositions qui nous et qui
nous étonne ou qui nous inquiète lorsque
le présent à public au tout début
octobre nous avait présenté ce
d'annoncer ce projet de loi il avait
insisté sur le fait que la stratégie
adoptée était de rendre plus difficile
la vie des associations loi 1901 objets
cultuels et plus attractive
les associations culturelles 1905 dont
vision une occasion de dire que nous
catholiques nous trouvions très bien
dans le régime tel qu'il est tel que
nous le vivons vous savez que nous
vivons le régime 905 avec des
aménagements de voitures et les
aménagements de nos associations
diocésaines sont des associations
cultuelles le conseil d'état les a
reconnus comme tels mais qui respecte
qui prennent en compte comme la loi de
1905 le laisser le rang des possibles
d'ailleurs qui rendent qu'ils prennent
en compte au maximum notre la structure
propre de l'église catholique donc ce
régime nous convient nous ne sommes pas
demandeurs d'un autre régime que celui
dans lequel nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui en
en france et par conséquent nous ne
sommes pas spécialement demandeur
d'amélioration de la situation des
associations cultuelles 1905
voilà maintenant si l'état souhaite nous
en donner nous en ferons usage comme
tout le monde mais pour le moment il
nous semble que deux je ne sais pas si
les accusations de 1900 objets cultuels
se trouve empêché dans leur
fonctionnement ou sont rendus moins
attrayante mais les accusations 1905 ne
sont pas rendus vraiment beaucoup plus
attrayante qu'elle n'était beaucoup de
dispositions qui sont prévues par cette
loi dont on peut sans doute comprendre
les là l'intérêt mais ont pour résultat
auront pour résultat si elles sont
votées de rendre plus difficile plus
compliqué la vie de nos de nous a sa
donation de baptisation cultuelle étant
donné notre organisation nous avons nous
une association diocésaine par diocèse
qui fait en gros en simplifiant une
centaine d'associations à peu près de
sézanne an en france
donc ce sont des structures qui ont
encore un peu de temps quand même
quelques capacités d'action quelques
passes et d'organisation nos frères
protestants dans une station différente
puisque eux ils ont plusieurs milliers
d'associations cultuelles lesquels sont
gérés par des personnes qui font ça avec
toute leur bonne volonté dans leurs
loisirs pour un certain nombre 1 ce
nombre d'entre elles comme un engagement
comme un engagement personnel et dont on
va rentrer par conséquent la vie
compliquée en ajoutant des dossiers à
remplir des procédures a fait et surtout
je me permets de 2,2 de dire aux
sénatrice et aux sénateurs que vous
n'êtes que ce qui est nous gêne un peu
dans dance étonnant dans ce projet de
loi est dans ce que nous pouvons
entendre parfois c'est le sentiment
malgré tout que les croyants les
citoyens français croyant seraient des
citoyens dont il faudrait avant tout se
méfier parce qu'il y a de fait
des gens qui ont des manoeuvres qui ont
des projets islamistes disons
séparatistes ou communautariste on peut
les appeler comme comme l'on veut on se
retrouve devant un projet de loi qui
qu'il le veuille ou non est
essentiellement répressif et donc donne
l'impression que même si les
associations cultuelles 1905 qui existe
aujourd'hui et qui fonctionne depuis des
décennies mérite de faire l'objet d'une
surveillance particulière et sont
contraints de réaffirmer constamment
encore encore davantage leur
appartenance à la communauté à la
communauté nationale
voilà donc c'est cet équilibre là que
qui nous étonne et dont nous demandons
bien d'où il vient et qui nous paraît
contraire à l'esprit qui nous avait été
annoncé le haut tout au tout début du
mois d'octobre
alors ceci étant dit il ya quelques
dispositions vous savez la bible que
l'opposition où la réserve principale
que nous formons porte sur l'article 27
donc sur la question de la déclaration a
réitéré de qualité cultuelle le ministre
de l'intérieur dans à l'assemblée
nationale a plus ou moins annoncé que
pour se répartir cette reconduction mais
ça serait fixé par décret dont acte mais
nous attendons de d'en être d'en être
certain
le conseil d'état avait suggéré qu'elle
soit permanente cette décla fin à cette
qualité culturelle et que le préfet
puisse à contester s'il y avait des
années des raisons de le faire
dans le projet de droite qui a été
présenté à l'assemblée il est prévu que
est à reconduire tous les tous les cinq
ans nous avons une mauvaise expérience
de
à une époque où les préfets devaient
donner leur accord pour chaque
libéralités reçu par une association
cultuelle organisant une mauvaise
expérience de préfecture qui n'était pas
capable de traiter ces dossiers
réellement dans les temps ainsi nombre
d'autres dispositions vision qui
concerne le patrimoine des associations
cultuelles sont présentés par le
gouvernement comme étant une faveur ou
un cadeau ou une manière d'améliorer la
situation des stations de 1900 des
associations culturelles 1905 je
voudrais apporter les précisions
suivantes
lorsqu'elles sont de 1905 ont été enfin
lorsque la loi de 1905
aucune association en france ne pouvait
détenir de patrimoine de patrimoine de
rapports et donc les associations
cultuelles était au régime général des
autres associations elles sont une
partie des associations 1901 spécifié
par leur objet cultuel voilà depuis 2014
si je ne me trompe il a été décidé que
les associations pouvaient détenir du
patrimoine de rapport pourquoi est ce
que la session cultuelle se verraient
privés de la liberté de gestion qui est
reconnue à toute association
quel con de ce particulier les
associations cultuelles qui ferait qu
elle devrait faire l'objet d'une d'une
loi de différentes et pour employer le
mot qui aujourd'hui le mot magique
pourquoi est ce que nous ferions l'objet
d'une discrimination dans la liberté de
gestion des
des associations encore une fois nous
catholiques ne demandons pas
spécialement ceux là mais puisque ce
sujet est mis sur la table
je tiens à préciser qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un privilège d'un avantage ou un
bénéfice mais il s'agirait simplement de
nous mettre au droit commun des
associations de notre cas organiser
notre pays tel qu'il est organisé dans
notre pays quant à l'article 6 qui
prévoit un contrat d'engagement
républicains ont soit à l'ordre d'au
moins deux remarques à faire le premier
c'est le terme de contrat ça a été dit
par exemple du juriste c'est toujours
étonnant de contracter avec avec l'état
au mans on demande une subvention il
s'agit là en l'occurrence c'est l'état
qui fixe les règles et tout le monde
doit obéir à la loi dans notre pays
est ce qu'il est la deuxième remarque
c'est porte sur ce contrat d'engagement
républicain il y a déjà une charte à
laquelle les actions sont censées
participer une charte qui fixe un
certain nombre de principes au gré des
autorisations des associations doivent
doivent souscrire
pourquoi faut-il encore à rajouter un
contrat cela prouve la faiblesse de ce
genre de dispositif
si bien que quand on aurait puisé les
charmes et de l'efficacité et de la
charte et du contrat il faudra inventer
encore un autre dispositif du même ordre
et donc de nouveau on se trouve là
devant une mesure qui va compliquer la
vie à deux des associations qui qui
énumère un certain nombre de principes
sur lesquels il n'y a pas d'opposition
de notre notre part évidemment mais
encore une fois qu'ils donnent
l'impression que dès qu'une association
et cultuelles ou de délit d'association
et confessionnelles elle serait à
surveiller 2
de plus près un certain nombre de
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
ont suggéré d'ajouter dans ce dans dans
la liste dans l'énumération de ces
principes le principe de laïcité avec
l'inconvénient de la non définition de
ce principe de laïcité 6,6 désigne la
neutralité de l'état
il n'y a pas de problème en matière
d'association à tout cela veut dire que
le secours catholique devrait une prise
être catholique que l entraide
protestante nous aurait plus être
protestante que le comité catholique
contre la faim et le développement
devraient plus être catholique non plus
voilà ce sont des questions auxquelles
la rédaction de cet article 6 ne répond
pas et ne permet pas d'être en sécurité
le fameux pas d'être on ne peint pas
d'être d'être très sûr voilà donc au
total nous comprenons bien et je
pourrais donner des exemples de qui s'il
le fallait mais vous êtes des
parlementaires vous connaissez mieux que
moi le
la réalité de la situation de notre pays
il y a des il ya des faits dont il faut
qu'il faut prévenir il ya des actes
qu'il faut punir il ya des menées dans
notre pays qu'il faut qu'il faut
combattre n'avons pas d'objection à cela
et c'est de réhabiliter de l'état de le
faire bien sûr mais nous avons le
sentiment partagé par l'ensemble des
représentants des cultes que pour lutter
contre une pincée d'islamistes c'est
l'ensemble des citoyens croyants de
notre pays qui vont voir l'organisation
de leur église leur confession se
trouvait alourdi est compliquée et
lançant une initiative que nous
pourrions prendre ce trouvé embarrassé
par toutes sortes de mesures répressives
et donc le sentiment qui en ressort
c'est encore une fois qu'il y aurait une
sorte de méfiance sur le fait même
d'être un citoyen sur le fait de
citoyens croyants je ne je n'attribue
aucun d'entre vous ni même d'ailleurs à
notre gouvernement cette méfiance mais
je dis simplement que qu'on le veuille
ou non une loi répressive ne peut que
donner 7 7
cette impression voilà monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur les messieurs les sénateurs ce
que je voulais vous partager en ce matin
et je suis évidemment prêt à répondre à
vos questions si vous le souhaitiez
merci je me dis alors
les âmes les rapporteurs ban avait rien
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
vous tous donc j'ai bien entendu une loi
répressive
alors que il me semblait que c'était
plutôt une loi qui essayait d'organiser
les choses et je suis pas sûr que
l'organisation soit forcément répressive
ça permet juste de clarifier de
clarifier les situations
j'aurais du coup quelques questions ont
déjà vous nous parler de la complexité
de faire cette déclaration pour les
associations cultuelles aux préfets qui
auront deux mois pour répondre
effectivement si vous pouvez déduire
enfin attribuer une déduction fiscale
aux dons que vous pourriez reçoit
puisque la déclaration au préfet est
bien lié au fait que vous allez recevoir
des dons et donc une défiscalisation qui
correspond bien à de l'argent public
puisque ce sont nos impôts qui irait et
dévots vos oeuvres
aujourd'hui vous êtes obligé de demander
un rescrit déjà fiscale pour pouvoir
obtenir cette autorisation tous les
combien est-ce que vous êtes obligé de
demander ce rescrit s qui se renouvelle
régulièrement ou pas et est-ce que
franchement complexité de cette
déclaration est vraiment plus lourde que
ce rescrit ensuite
une autre un autre texte avait fait
couler de l'encré et y compris dans les
milieux catholiques qui était la loi de
notre collègue françoise gatel qui est
on ira peut-être un mot tout à l'heure
concernant les établissements privés
hors contrat qui justement cherché à
réglementer de façon un peu plus carré
que ça ne pouvait l'être jusqu'à présent
est ce qu'aujourd'hui puisque elle a je
pense été jugée liberticide etc
j'ai aussi lu des choses très extrême
dans les journaux sur ce sujet est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez sur
l'enseignement catholique des
conséquences connues des écoles qui
auraient été fermés ou martyrisé par ce
texte
et ensuite quand vous parlez de la
laïcité dans les engagements
républicains en tout cas en sortie de
commissions dans le texte ça n'y figure
pas on est bien d'accord
on demande de respecter les valeurs de
la république et non pas au niveau des
associations d'être laïque est ce qu'on
peut bien comprendre si peut-être madame
lesage brigneau puis je vais pas prendre
à part entre non parce que je pense que
c'est important qu'on a un échange avec
tous les membres de la commission
j'ai entendu on a entendu vos
inquiétudes et vos questionnements sur
cette loi
je suis pas persuadé que les lois soient
précises au mais la loi elle elle essaye
de faire face à une difficulté commune
que nous avons et vous en avez parlé
vous en avait parlé
vous avez évidemment noté ce à quoi de
nous devons faire face
juste pour vous dire que vous vous vous
interrogez sur la signature d'un
engagement d'une charte à l'article 6
juste pour préciser c'est aussi un
engagement qui sera demandé à toutes les
associations qui bénéficieront de ces
bons sont vus libre donc c'est pas voilà
bon moi je voulais juste une question
alors peut-être qu'il est pas tout à
fait avec les propos que vous avez tenus
et qui qui qui est lié quand même
sans trahir de secret parce que sans
voilà vous moi je voulais savoir sur ce
sujet là ce combat que nous avons à
mener contre une partie de notre
population
vous avez des échanges inter religieux
régulièrement
c'est évident que vous avez des échanges
inter religieux je voudrais savoir si
vous en parler avec les représentants de
la communauté musulmane
si vous avez abordé ce sujet auquel la
france doit faire face parce que ça une
réalité voilà les est-ce que vous avez
pu échanger pour trouver d'autres
solutions entre vous entre croyants je
pense que ça c'est aussi important qu'on
puisse savoir comment vous vous l'avez
abordé entre croyants ce sujet que nous
avons alors d'aujourd'hui merci merci
mesdames mais les sénatrices donc vous
merci vraiment pour ces questions sur la
première question concernant le rescrit
pour le moment se réinscrit à redemander
lorsqu'une association diocésaine il
faut que le père de woillemont med n'a
pas reçu de libéralités pendant une
certaine période et donc elle en ferait
de nouveau état à ce moment là il est à
il est à redemander je préférais de cinq
ans de fête mais c'est une réalité qui
se présente relativement rarement parce
que pour le moment nous avons la chance
d'avoir des libéralités régulière donc
nous n'en sommes pas obligés à ce
travail juridique sur ce sujet là
honnêtement nous avons une centaine de
l'association diocésaine
elles sont relativement structure et ne
sera jamais qu'un dossier de plus à
remplir c'est pas mais je souligne le
la gêne que cela représente pour
d'autres pour d'autres cultes comme les
protestants dont cliquer ont une
association cultuelle par lieu par lieu
de culte et par conséquent moins
d'administration et de capacités
d'administration que nous connu en avant
je n'ai pas de principes moelleux
personnellement je comprends très bien
que l'état vérifie il vérifie ce qu'il
ce qu'il fait de tout ce qui est fait
des déductions fiscales qu'il accorde
vous avez dit que c'était l'argent de
nos impôts qui finançait novo heures
vous dit ce sont les heures des
catholiques y sont aussi des citoyens
français et dans une grande partie paie
des impôts tout de même où entraînant
peut pas moins que les autres que les
autres citoyens de notre pays donc sans
tout ce sont les oeuvres des catholiques
des citoyens catholiques français
concernant l'école orconte les écoles
hors contrat et la loi gatel donc
l'enseignement catholique et organiser
massivement avec sous contrat comme vous
comme vous le savez bien et nous les
vingt ans toi comme évêque le
le plus clair de mon temps consiste à
supporter à soutenir et à encourager à
vivifier cet enseignement catholique
sous contrat je n'occupe pas
spécialement de l'enseignement hors
contrat donc je vois la jeune raconte là
je crois qu'on est devant un principe
plus beaucoup plus large que ce que je
peux représenter qui est la question de
la part de liberté que l'état veut bien
donner aux parents et de responsabilité
dans l'éducation des indications des
enfants on peut entrer dans tout un
débat philosophique sur sur le sur le
sujet je ne crois pas qu'ils aient enfin
il faut dit il faudrait regarder pour
chaque chaque école dans chaque cas sur
ce qui ce qui sait ce qui s'est passé je
comprends très bien la problématique que
le présent à publique et le ministre
intérieur souligne enfin et où il
exprime très très clairement de la
déscolarisation d'un certain nombre
d'enfants notamment deux petites filles
d'un stand de nos quartiers qui camoufle
en fait le fait qu'elles vont dans des
espèces de d'école de pseudo école et je
comprends très bien la nécessité de
lutter contre contre cela mais sept
jours c'est toujours pareil et j'en
viens à ce que donc vous disiez sur le
fait que la loi rsca l'eau et répressive
alors qu'elle essaie d'organiser
certes elle organise notamment des
réalités qui existent déjà qui
fonctionne très bien et qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin qu'il semble quine de ceux qui ne
pensaient pas avoir besoin de davantage
de davantage d'organisations
alors après il faut faire dans notre
pays de la place au à nos concitoyens
musulmans il faut leur permettre de
trouver une place et à motorisation à
notre pays c'est une difficulté est
spécial et si vous permettez peut être
une considération plus pas comment il
faut dire plus lui disons plus
philosophique
je crois pouvoir je crois pouvoir dire
quand même que
depuis la vidéo dans laquelle nous
trouverons en france est la suivante
c'est que le mode que nous avons trouvée
la semaine mais la séparation même entre
l'état et les églises s'est fait dans
une matrice chrétienne et dans un pays
qui a été façonné par des siècles de
christianisme et donc c'est là le
principal de la religion chrétienne qui
rend possible en quelque sorte cette
séparation telle que nous la tel que
nous l'avons conçu le l'islam et les
musulmans n'ont pas vécu cette histoire
et ils n'ont pas de ce même principe de
séparation dont nous avons du mal à
faire entrer le wpt à aider nos
concitoyens musulmans à entrer dans
cette dans cette matrice là je
personnellement je pense qu'il est
possible avec le temps qu'ils y entrent
il est nécessaire de les y aider je
pense que ça que ça peut être ça sera
bénéfique même pour eux-mêmes du point
de vue de la de la foi musulmane ou de
la religion musulmane que d'être dans
une relation avec l'état et la
communauté politique différente de celle
qu'ils connaissent dans les pays dans
les pays à majorité à majorité musulmane
mais c'est un long un long travail bon
est ce qu'il faut pour cela nous
compliquer encore un peu ou beaucoup
l'existence c'est un c'est ce que vous
avez ce dont vous avez a décidé que le
précéda is it et j'entends bien qu'il
n'ait pas encore dans la loi je sais je
le mentionnais parce que il dans les
débats la scène nationale il en a été
question de l'ajouter à l'article l art
et l article 6 alors tous à vos articles
6 de fait il est pour toutes les
associations
ça ce contrat d'engagement républicains
seraient pour toutes les associations
dont act dont de fait ça ne concerne pas
qu'une association à nous mais voilà il
vient ajouter encore d d d d engagement
nous vivons en france sous un régime de
liberté d'association plus tôt et dans
un bruissement personnellement que c'est
le climat global notre société qui fait
que les gens ne les citoyens entre
d'enfin respecte les règles de la
république et les lois de notre notre
pays je le lis est inquiétant qu'on soit
obligé de la firme et puis de le
réaffirmer devient par une charte le
réaffirmer par un contrat et je veux
personnellement je ne sais pas je enfin
je vois bien le seul intérêt du contrat
ça sera la répression c'est à dire que
le signe un contrat ne fera pas que ceux
qui ne veulent pas le vivre le vivront
mais s'il ya un coq signe un contrat
permettra de punir ceux qui les y
enseigner ne le respecteront pas mais il
ne fera pas qu'il le vivront et donc le
défi devant lequel collectivement nous
trouvons c'est de donner du goût et du
sens pour vivre les les règles notre
république et le pas et partager et ce
que nous appelons les les valeurs les
valeurs de la de la république alors
quand à nos échanges inter religieux oui
nous abordons cette question je me
permets de peut-être que je devrais pas
parler au nom des eaux non des musulmans
mais je peux quand même rapporter vous
rapporter le fait suivant alors que les
prisons république nous a présenté ce
qui allait être le discours des mureaux
la réaction des trois responsables
musulmans qui étaient présents à
l'elysée a été de dire cette loi va nous
aider à lutter contre nos propres
intégristes
donc elle va nous aider mais le climat
s'est un peu transformés paradoxalement
après et notamment autour d'eux après
l'assassinât de samuel paty et de
l'assassinât de nice mais surtout autour
de la après l'assassinât de samuel bâti
et à cause de tout ce qui a été vécu à
ce moment là autour de la question des
caricatures encore une fois qui a donné
à nos concitoyens musulmans l'impression
que finalement ce que la république
voulait c'était qu'elle est organisée le
fait que l'on pouvait se moquer de la
foi musulmane est donc cette loi a été
comprise par eux comme allant de nouveau
dans ce sens là d'une sorte de
contingentement et de mépris de la foi
musulmane et donc on à moi j'ai assisté
dans no 1 dans douze échange on a
assisté à un changement de voiliers de
l'attitude globale à cause de cette
exaltation de d'un certain nombre de
caricatures
je me permets personnellement chacun
peut pas là-dessus pense ce qu'il veut
je pense qu'il faut l'eau pour ma part
je pense qu'il faut laisser la liberté
aux caricaturistes mai les quatrièmes
mais les caricatures de charlie hebdo ne
me paraissent pas représenter le sommet
de l'esprit français et j'ai
personnellement je ne vois pas je ne
prends pas comme citoyen français obligé
de considérer que que ces caricatures
représente le meilleur de l'intelligence
française telle qu'elle a pu se
distiller pendant pendant les siècles
voilà on a eu un peu la donne un peu
l'impression parfois que c'était reparti
du catéchisme qui allait nous être nous
être imposée
les choses ont un peu changé mais ce
sable à cette affaire a changé un peu
l'attitude des voiliers la compréhension
de l' équilibre de la loi par nos
interlocuteurs
musulmans alors suivez dès la parole à
ceux qui me l'ont demandé
tout d'abord madame nathalie goulet puis
madame françoise gatel oui mais c'est le
président merci beaucoup
moi je suis plutôt très favorable à
l'ensemble des dispositifs même si son
déclaratif qui ont trait aux
associations pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on lui réclame depuis longtemps
alors que cela crée une perturbation en
raison du principe républicain d'égalité
devant la loi je comprends bien mais en
même temps on ne règle pas les problèmes
en créant des discriminations ou des
divergences dans l'application de la loi
à l'égalité devant la loi c'est quand
même un principe fondamental moi je vais
vous poser de questions
la première est ce que vous pourriez
nous donner approximativement les modes
de financement du culte catholique en
france notamment 6 mb par exemple des
financements étrangers parce que
j'ignore complètement
et puis nous dire un mot des prêtres
étrangers qui viennent en france
ce serait intéressant de savoir quel
type de formation ils ont et qu'elle est
qu elle
contrôle entre guillemets vous avez sur
sur leur formation merci madame gatel
mais ensuite monsieur merci monsieur le
président je vous remercie de votre
franchise l'expression de vos craintes
sur 7 sur cette loi 1905 a été vécu par
la religion catholique comme une
atteinte à la liberté de culte et à ceux
qui a fondé vous l'avait dit et ce n'est
pas un avis morale notre notre notre
société 2021 il y a à nouveau une
interrogation de notre société sur les
exigences qu'il a fondé la république
avec un principe que la loi doit
permettre l'exercice et la pratique de
ses convictions religieuses ou
philosophiques mais que celles ci ne
doivent pas porter atteinte à la
république
il y as depuis 1905 un certain nombre de
cultes qui vivent très bien avec la
république y la république vit très bien
avec les cultes et nous avons
aujourd'hui un détournement d'une
religion vous l'avez rappelé qu'il n'est
pas fondatrices de notre société et qui
s'est profondément développé pour des
régions on va le dire historique
culturel ou économique
et cette même religion est aujourd'hui
victime de ceux qui la détourne à des
fins de conquête sociétal et politique
ce qui amène sans doute le gouvernement
a proposé ce texte
donc je vous pose une question très
simple et de manière paisible
on a on va dire
un effet collatéral pour l'ensemble des
religions que nous connaissons de
l'exigence de la république de se
protéger contre des gens qui n'ont qu'un
objectif c'est agressé cette société qui
font des pratiquants de cette religion
musulmane des victimes donc j'entends on
va dire le désagrément la gêne mais ma
question est simple est-ce que au fond
n'y at-il pas si on fait la lecture des
effets de cette loi à une échelle de 4
ou 5 ans y aura-t-il une entrave à votre
liberté d'exercer votre culte de le
pratiquer et pensez vous qu'il y à là
plutôt une exigence républicaine qui
peut servir même à protéger l'ensemble
des cuirs tu remercies sianga tel
monsieur oui merci monsieur le président
lee l'église catholique a une longue
histoire et au fil des siècles des
siècles y compris dans notre pays
il lui est arrivé de considérer où
certains catholiques et non des moindres
que finalement la loi de l'église était
supérieure à la loi de l'état de la
république de la royauté etc
certains disent que le fanatisme et
congénitale ou religion certains pensent
qu'au contraire les religions peuvent
vivre dans un cadre parfaitement
rationnel je voulais vous demander en
vertu sa grande expérience et pas
seulement la vôtre mais qui est celle de
l'institution que vous représentez
comment on peut lutter contre le
fanatisme
parce que finalement ce à quoi nous
assistons c'est le fait que des
personnes sont dans l'incapacité de
considérer ou de penser que la loi de la
république est supérieur ou en tout cas
doit s'appliquer en toutes circonstances
quelles que soient les considérations
liées à la religion elle même
c'est ma première question et la
deuxième qui est courte et de savoir
quel est votre sentiment par rapport au
financement d elise des cultes par des
nations étrangères ou des intérêts ou
des groupes étrangers
est-ce que cela vous paraît légitime
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
légitime de réguler cela voir eux de
l'empêcher merci messieurs parole est un
monsieur richard oui monsieur le
président la réflexion est gras dans le
même sens que celles de certains
collègues
évidemment quand on aborde un sujet
comme ça qu'on est tenté de verser dans
l'histoire profonde la bagarre le
conflit entre l' empire romain
germanique et la papauté le gallicanisme
cetera dont les sons sainte côté prenons
la situation contemporaine dans notre
état de droit
toute liberté connaît des limites
c'est ça la fonction du législateur et
donc la loi de 1905 comme dans toute une
série d'autres domaines fixe des limites
dont l'essentiel tient en deux mots
l'ordre public dont c'est la
responsabilité dont la villa dont le don
la république à la à la responsabilité
ceci englobe la faculté pour la
république de fixer un cadre à
l'exercice des cultes et je dirais que
c'est un cadre allégé par rapport à
beaucoup l'état dans des situations de
type concordataire au finalement les
moyens attribués par la puissance
publique aux religions se traduisent par
une série de contrôles et leurs règles
qui sont beaucoup plus profond que dans
d'autres cas c'est sale équilibre de la
laïcité de la loi de 1905 donc une
évolution que des collègues ont très
bien décrite se produit au cours des
dernières générations et suppose une
modification à mon avis extrêmement
légère des modalités du contrôle
qu'exerce le exercera la république sur
l'exercice de cette liberté
il me semble que il y avait beaucoup de
subjectivité dans votre présentation
monseigneur c'est-à-dire il ya toujours
le sentiment de etc mais que votre rôle
quand vous exprimer au nom de l'église
est tout de même d'essayer de rester à
la réalité des fêtes et des règles et de
ne pas amplifier ce qui risque d'être
une incompréhension l'incompréhension ne
fait rien progresser et il me semble que
vous ne pouvez être que d'accord avec le
principe que cette fonction
d'encadrement de lumière 6 des cultes
qui incombe à la république doit
s'exercer dans des conditions identiques
entre les cultes quelles que soient les
différences entre eux
alors quand vous citer par exemple la
difficulté pour la confession
protestante de répondre à la règle de la
déclarations périodiques parce qu'elle
est organisée en milliers de communautés
locales mais pardon dans les
prérogatives d'organisation des
religions qui reviennent à l'état pour
exercer sa mission de contrôle de
l'ordre public
il n'est pas illégitime que l'état
adresse aux religions des
recommandations ou des demandes quant à
leur organisation interne et c'est bien
tout ce nom nous sommes en train de
discuter en ce qui me concerne la la
confession musulmane où cette
organisation interne est
particulièrement défectueuse vue de ce
point de vue et enfin dernier point
puisque ça sera aussi un des moments je
dirais et motifs de notre débat la
liberté de l'enseignement depuis la
révolution a toujours subsister et elle
a toujours été encadrée et donc oui il
me semble que c'est au contraire un
progrès que la définition des règles de
l'enseignement en famille
or d'école soit assortie de principes
qui garantissent l'intégrité de l'enfant
est à dire 2 faire pendant deux trois
ans à 11 ans bénéficié à l'enfant si je
veux dire d'un enseignement familiale
par nyon qui n'ont aucune qualification
pour le faire et me semble-t-il à
détournement de cette liberté
donc le fait que enfin jamie dire on
s'assure du minimum de capacité et de
responsabilité des parents pour savoir
s'ils sont en mesure d'exercer
l'enseignement de leurs enfants dans des
conditions qui leur nuisent pas me
semble aussi être simplement un progrès
merci monsieur richard il reste deux
questions
madame de la gontrie mais qui est en
visioconférence donc peut-être va-t-elle
apparaître sur l'écran qui est derrière
nous je ne cédera la voilà
vous avez la parole même de rencontrer à
votre micro très bien merci
je voudrais remercier les intervenants
de comment dire delà de la nuance et la
subtilité de son propos je lui ai je lui
indique que pour ma part je suis à la
fois dans l'opposition au gouvernement
et dans l'opposition au sénat ce que je
suis membre du groupe socialiste et que
les sujets religieux ne sont pas
traditionnellement des sujets sur lequel
nous sommes très versée est donc
vraiment je voulais le remercier de ses
nuances mais nous sommes donc là pour
l'examiner ce texte dit lois de la
république et au fond je pense qu'il
faut mettre un terme à une forme de
comment dire
l'hypocrisie le mot de trop excessif qui
a été abordé déjà par certains il ne
s'agit pas d' entamer la liberté
religieuse ça cet acquis en france nous
estimons à juste titre avoir un problème
avec une part de ceux qui se
revendiquent d'une religion en
l'occurrence la région musulmane
si je dis cela c'est que il ya qu il
peut y avoir mais de manière très
marginale des problèmes dit mais avec
des membres d'autres religions mais j'ai
envie de dire que finalement nous avons
su que le trou les cantonais et y faire
face et surtout il ne suscite pas la
même inquiétude en terme de violences
dans la société
donc ma question est celle-ci
qu'imaginez-vous qui serait pertinent
sachant que ça a été rappelée à
l'instant il est difficile de considérer
qu'il peut il est possible d'appliquer
un régime à une religion et pas aux
autres
et sachant que par ailleurs la liberté
religieuse persiste donc c'est je me
tourne plutôt vers le
invité pour savoir quels sont quels sont
ses éventuelles préconisations car
autrement
effectivement nous ne pourrons pas
proposer les dispositions qui
s'appliqueraient aux seins mais pas aux
autres
donc s'ils pouvaient nous aider à
avancer vers la voie d'une solution ce
serait fort intéressant joueurs mercier
simoneau de la gontrie dernière question
en tous les cas pour ce premier tour
monsieur philippe bas après monsieur
région mais nous et sur le président
répond je sais pas si monsieur le
président il me semble quant à moi que
la loi de 1905 offre déjà beaucoup de
réponses aux questions que nous posons
ce qui d'ailleurs n'interdit nullement
comme cela a déjà été fait à de
nombreuses reprises dans notre histoire
de l'aménager la loi de 1905 comporte
des obligations comptables pour les
associations cultuelles
elle régit leurs ressources leurs
dépenses et leurs réserves elles
prévoient les dépôts des réserves à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations le
contrôle du ministère des finances et de
l'inspection des finances et la
possibilité de dissoudre par un tribunal
toute association cultuelle qui ne
respecteraient pas ces règles
elle introduit ce qu'elle appelle elle
même la police des cultes fondé
naturellement sur la nécessité de
préserver l'ordre public comme alain
richard l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que c'est que la police des
cultes c'est un certain nombre de règles
dont la violation peut entraîner des
sanctions
la loi de 1905 prévoit la surveillance
des autorités sur l'exercice des cultes
dans l'intérêt de l'ordre public
elle interdit les réunions politiques
dans les lieux de culte et le fait de
faire pression sur quiconque et de
quelques manières que ce soit en vue de
le déterminer a exercé ou à s'abstenir
d'exercer un culte elle interdit toute
provocation directe à résister à
l'exécution des lois ou aux autres laits
actes légaux de l'autorité publique par
un ministre du culte et le fait de
soulever ou d'art mais une partie des
citoyens contre les autres ou encore de
mettre en cause un citoyen chargé d'un
service public
et elle a sorti toutes ces interdictions
de sanctions pénales qui peuvent être
très lourdes puisqu'elles peuvent
culminer à des peines de deux années
d'emprisonnement
elle prévoit aussi la responsabilité
civile des actions culturelles dans
lesquelles ces infractions seraient
commises
donc vous voyez que quand on parle de
répression au sens juridique du terme la
répression qu'est ce que c'est c'est de
d'établir des infractions et de
permettre leur sanction pénale ce serait
intéressant monseigneur de moulins
beaufort que vous nous disiez si vous
avez connaissance de poursuite qui
aurait pu être exercées contre les
ministres du culte catholique dans les
précédentes décennies
en application de ces dispositions il me
semble pas qu'il y en ait et c'est là
que nous ouvrons un débat qui me paraît
être intéressant parce que plusieurs
d'entre vous chers collègues ont dit
mais si l'on veut lutter contre la
subversion l'idéologie politique qu'est
l'islamisme
alors il faut imposer des règles à
toutes les religions même celles qui ont
trouvé leur régime de croisière dans la
république qui ne subissent aucune
poursuite actuellement je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cette manière de voir
je considère que quand il s'agit de
lutter contre la subversion islamiste
on ne lutte pas contre une religion on
ne limite pas à l'exercice d'un culte on
lutte contre une action politique qu'on
a déjà
dans le cadre de la loi de 1905 les
moyens de combattre ces moyens ne sont
pas utilisés il faudrait d'ailleurs
demandé aussi au ministre de l'intérieur
au ministre de la justice comment ils
sont actuellement mobilisés avant
d'apprécier les dispositions à prendre
pour que ces moyens soit amplifiée
contre ceux qui aujourd'hui menace la
république
mais à partir du moment où ce n'est plus
liberté de culte qui est visé ça n'est
plus le libre exercice du culte ça n'est
plus la liberté d'exprimer ses
convictions religieuses ou
philosophiques
alors on rentre dans un domaine dans
lequel on peut agir efficacement sans
apporter des contraintes supplémentaires
à l'exercice de tous les cultes
c'est la question que je pose en même
temps qu'une idée que je formule bien
c'est président après celle est très
content alors parce que sinon ce sera
vous montrer quoi enseigne monseigneur
je suis ceux qui pensent que 1 est vrai
problème qui est qui qui concerne la
religion musulmane et qui est à mon sens
une des raisons de la montée de 2,2 de
la radicalisation chez un certain nombre
de ces de ses fidèles
c'est l'absence de qualification d' un
très très grand nombre de d'imams dans
ce pays savaient que bien sûr ils sont
choisis par les représentants des
mosquées enfin vous savez tout ça donc
le texte que nous examinons ne parle
absolument pas de qualification des
ministres du culte la question je
voudrais vous poser très direct que
pensez-vous de l'inscription éventuels
qui ne figurent pas dans ce texte d'une
exigence de qualification
professionnelle pour les ministres du
culte poids merci si ce rachat
eh bien vous avez la parole trees les
sénateurs merci pour toutes ces
questions qui me permettent de préciser
mon propos tout en précisant à cet
nombre de répondre à un certain nombre
de vos deux de vos demandes
ma réponse globale si vous voulez c'est
que je ne dirais pas que cette loi va
cette saison va pas empêcher rice
catholique de vivre dont connu d'autres
de la même façon et bien pire
donc c'est celle ci n'est pas n'est pas
la pire que que nous connaissions dans -
elle représente une
inflexion dans le cette foire aux vins
devraient entrer ou représentera une
inflexion dans le dans le traitement des
des pulls temps en france et mon
sentiment est qu'un qui n'est pas qu'un
sentiment non partant de mon analyse
alors je peux être uniquement dans le
ressenti mon analyse qui rejoint
quelques unes des remarques qui ont été
faites c'est que il eût fallu il
faudrait appliquer strictement la loi
telle qu'elle existe déjà à dire qu'on
rajoute des lois alors que depuis des
décennies il y à 1 seconde de loi qui
existe et que en réalité on n'applique
pas et il y alors je viendrai dans le
détail un certain nombre de pratiques
qui auraient pu être depuis longtemps
depuis longtemps condamné je le
signalais en commençant l'intérêt du
titre 1 qui s'opposent à l'âme aux
mariages forcés la polygamie et à
l'excision la question la polygamie une
question bien connue des assistantes
sociales ou des services sociaux dans
notre dans un certain nombre de parties
de notre pays et à laquelle on sait peu
on sait peu attaquées alors je vais
répondre aux questions de donc de madame
de madame goulet concernant le mode de
financement de l'église catholique
l'église catholique elle vient par des
dons des fidèles peut-être des dons qui
sont faits au cours de la messe ou d
office un baptême ou à l'occasion d'un
d'un sacrement qui peuvent être des dons
faits chaque année annuellement
nous appelons le denier de l'église
était mis en place après 1905 lorsque
les prêtres sont retrouvés sans aucune
ressource et qu'ils en ont été réduits
aller quêter régulièrement porte à porte
donc petit à petit cette pratique
humiliante a été organisée dans un
système s'appelle aujourd'hui le denier
de l'église et qui fonctionne très bien
et dont nous ne souhaitons pas nous ne
demandons rien d'autre
et comme j'ai pu le dire à l'assemblée
nationale
l'église de france ne reçoit aucune
subvention de l'extérieur n'est aucune
aide de l'extérieur c'est nous qui
soutenons et le saint-siège par
notamment dans les politiques appellent
le denier de saint-pierre est une quête
fait chaque année et d'autre part par
une soutenons beaucoup de deux diocèses
ou deux réalités ecclésiales dans les
pays d'afrique ou d'asie
nous avons encore les moyens de faire
cela et c'est dans ce sens là que vend
les flux les flux financiers
alors après on peut jamais exclure que
un jour un américain il a envie de faire
un don
c'est un peu toujours arriver et je n'ai
personnellement aucune espèce de réserve
sur le fait que ça puisse être contrôlée
là dessus je ne me suis pas prononcé je
ne prononcerai pas toutes les mesures de
contrôle financier sont les bienvenus
l'expérience prouve et méfiance de la
vie m'a prouvé que tout touffu d'argent
qui n'est pas un peu surveillé risque un
jour de susciter un canal de dérivation
qui le fait rêver dans la poche pour la
qualité pas prévu donc je n'ai pour ma
part aucune réserve sur c'est sur ces
règles là en revanche on peut
s'interroger sur je me suis permis de
m'interroger sur le fait que la liberté
de gestion des dons que nous recevons ne
soit pas respectée alors une autre
source de financement je tiens à le dire
c'est sur les legs que nous pouvons que
nous pouvons recevoir qui sont encore
aujourd'hui une source de financement
très très très importante dans lequel il
peut se trouver des immeubles que pour
le moment nous sommes obligés de vendre
que ne pouvons pas garder ce nom pas
n'ont pas n'ont pas l'usagé
ce qui fait qu'après nous avons de
l'argent que nous plaçons il faut bien
faire quelque chose en prenant attendant
de pouvoir de pouvoir lui de pouvoir
l'utiliser et livre garantir en
particulier le paiement des salaires car
nous avons aujourd'hui quand même un
certain nombre de salariés qu'il faut
bien pouvoir notre qu'il faut bien que
nous puissions garantir les salaires que
nous leur devons les comptes sont
publiés ils sont certifiés ils font
l'objet d'une sorte de vérification
comme monsieur le sénateur ben a pu le
rappeler nous faisons l'objet de
beaucoup de déjà de beaucoup de
surveillance
alors concernant les prêtres étrangers
qui viennent en france ils ne sont
au contraire des imams détachées ne sont
pas des fonctionnaires de l'état qui les
envoient et ils viennent dans le cadre
d'une convention entre deux diocèses
donc adieu c'est les africains ou
asiatiques ou autre ou européens et puis
un de 16 ans ne cesse français ils sont
rémunérés comme prêtre français ils sont
pris en charge par la cavimac qui notre
association neuf revers notre caisse de
2,2 de retraite
un salon viennent ici pour faire des
études soit dans des catholiques soit
dans des universités françaises et
contribua au rayonnement de notre notre
pays de ce coup de ce point de vue là et
leur formation est assurée dans des
séminaires ou des universités
catholiques ou pas d'ailleurs enfin ça
dépend c'est donc pour le coup n'avait
pas vraiment de chacun n'est ce pas dans
le pays d'origine soit à rome soit chez
nous un certain nombre étudient ou ont
étudié par exemple je suis catholique de
paris ou de toulouse ou de etc mais
aussi à la sorbonne mais aussi dans
d'autres universités à reims le moins
trois prêtres étrangers qui étudie à
l'université de reims
et puis nous organisons donc des
sessions d'accueil et nous les
réunissons régulièrement ils sont
insérés dans le tissu de nos paroisses
pour ce qui est de la surveillance ou du
contrôle que nous pouvons exercer sur
eux là dessus il n'est pas plus fort que
celui que j'exerce sur les coups de 10
garçons nous évêques sur les prêtres du
diocèse mais pas moindre voilà
concernant la loi de donc madame madame
gatel vous avez souligné donc
l'importance de même de former des
exigences républicaines et ça moi je
n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas d'objection à cela la seule
chose qu'elle existe et nous nous sommes
dans une situation où on en renfort
soukounan réitère la la la la la force
personnellement comme citoyen français
ce qui me désole c'est que c'est une
marque de faiblesse par rapport à c'est
à dire que nous entérinons le fait
qu'elles sont qu'elles ne sont peut être
que ce projet républicain n'est pas
portée alors qu'il s'agit précisément
d'une action de 2 d'essayer de deux
d'encourager tout le monde à le vivre
alors l'action globale du ce projet de
loi n'a de sens que dans une action
globale lorsque le président a pu lui
avait présentée lorsqu'il après il
l'annoncé dans son discours du bureau il
y avait été pris dans un discours global
aussi avec une analyse sociale donc dont
quelques pans commence à se dévoiler
puisque a été annoncé un plan qui qu'un
plan social aussi qui peut qui peut
contribuer à enrichir le le comment dire
la manière dans notre pays et c'est 2-2
d'intégrer ou de facilités où de
réintégrer un certain nombre de ces deux
de ses citoyens donc je par rapport à
l'allemagne à 105 je tiens à préciser
une chose quelque chose quelque chose
quelque personne se sont étonnés que
l'on la présence d'un mode liberté la
vérité c'est que l'église catholique
pisco pas français en 1905 est très
content de la loi de séparation j'ai pu
le vérifier pour ma part en lisant la
semaine religieuse de paris en voyant la
réaction des avec car le lendemain de
cette du vote de cette loi
la première chose qu'on fait les évêques
ça a été de se réunir
car jusque là une pouvait se réunir avec
l'autorisation du gouvernement et au
risque de sanction qui pouvait être la
perte du salaire équipe le traitement
qu'ils pouvaient être plus grave encore
si le seul le faisait en dehors de
l'autorisation du gouvernement donc de
fait comme ça a été soulignée le cadre
qui organisait loi 1905 est beaucoup
plus léger que celui qui organisait le
concordat équipe organisée que peut
organiser un certain nombre de de
concordat dans d'autres pays je dirais
dire que les évêques se sont d'autant
plus vite consolé de la loi de mieux de
la séparation que assez vite la loi de
séparation à être levés la respiration
était suivie du vote d'une loi étendant
le congé dominical à l'ensemble des
salariés qui a été loi qui a été votée
par une coalition les députés
socialistes et deux députés catholiques
et dont les évêques se sont félicités
kylesa consoler de cette loi 1905 après
que la population française réagit
différemment à cette fois ça c'est une
chose et en particulier à la pratique au
fait des inventaires mais sur la
séparation elle-même elle veut elle
était elle était je crois nécessaire
elle était très attendu en chute de
conseil d'état a veillé à ce qu' une a
permis qu'il y ait une interprétation
ils ont libéré de la loi dans l'esprit
que l'on dit être celui de d'aristide
briand plutôt que celui des tout
premiers promoteurs de cette loi est ce
qui fait que nous arrivons à 1 et qui
sommes arrivés un équilibre qui permet
en france de vivre et dans lequel de
fait porte personnellement je comprends
très bien que
l'état français les encourage veut
encourager et même un peu plus qu
encourager nos concitoyens musulmans à
faire entrer dans ce cadre-là leurs
institutions
donc moi je comprends très bien le
principe de la migration et nous
comprenons très bien le principe est de
pousser à la migration des associations
1901 objets cultuels vers les années les
associations 1905
après pourquoi faut-il pour autant
durcir le statut d de 1905 qui sont déjà
désolation plus contraintes que les
autres dans notre système français et
dont ils s'y seraient déjà bon de
respecter et de faire respecter
l'ensemble l'intégralité des dessins des
dispositions et on pourrait faire ceci
sans attenter à l'égalité républicaine
qui est évidemment un principe auquel on
ne peut pas revenir peu plus sur quel
est le remède au fanatisme
moi je dirais que je vais prendre
l'exemple
un exemple historique si vous voulez
paradoxalement je dirais que le remède
au fanatisme ou au radicalisme comme on
le dit parfois aujourd'hui c'est la
radicalité de la fois le chrétien à la
figure du chrétien le moins fanatiques
c'est françois d'assise qui est aussi le
plus radical voilà il vit pleinement
radicalement sa foi chrétienne mais
précisément à cause cette radicalité là
il ne vit pas dans une espèce de
radicalisme politique ou social est au
contraire il est capable de fraternité
universelle y compris dans sa fameuse
rencontre avec avec le sultan avec tout
y est toutes les commandes dire toutes
les équipes aussi t27 de 2,7 de cette
rencontre
donc je pourrais pas je dirais que c'est
pas moins de religion ce serait plutôt
un peu plus un bus devraient religion
qui serait un meilleur remède
au fanatisme plutôt qu'une espèce d'idée
fantasmer delà de la religion entretenu
aujourd'hui facilement entretenus sur
les réseaux sociaux sur internet et qui
qui ne permet pas précisé petit qui
donne une teinte a forcément une
véritable expérience et de dieu et de la
haie du type de relation que dieu peut
créer que peut nous appeler à créer
entre nous on peut ré interpréter cette
façon là aussi les guerres de religion
les guerres de religions ne sont pas
sont pas le fait des saints quant à l'or
quant au financement de l'église par des
nations étrangères dont je comprends
très bien que je n'ai pas de deux de
réserve à ce que l'on contrôle le fait
que des églises soient financés par des
coups qu'on ne veuille pas que une
religion soit financée par des états
étrangers
on voit bien aujourd'hui que à sa nombre
de mosquées c'est un fait c'est un fait
certain servent de deux prolongations de
la politique intérieure d'un certain
nombre de pays mais ça fait des 10 des
décennies que cela existe et ça fait des
décennies que l'on n'aurait pu lutter
contre cela ça fait des décennies que la
france attend des décennies la france
accordé des visas à des à des imams
allées et venues d'algérie au moment
même où l'algérie refusé le moindre visa
à toute personne qui pouvait avoir l'air
d'être des trains religieux ou
chrétien ou d'être tout simplement à un
chrétien identifiées donc de ce point de
vue là nous la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons est aussi quand même
le résultat de
de ce que nous avons laissé faire donc
moi personnellement le remède que je
propose c'est d'appliquer d'appliquer la
loi je pense avec seul à avoir répondu
un certain nombre de questions notamment
celle de madame la gontrie sur ce que
j'imagine
personnellement je crie j'imagine c'est
que on applique déjà loi telle qu'elle
est déjà l ai déjà elle est déjà
fortement
l'organisation des cultes en france
c'est déjà une chose bien vite bien en
place le tout c'est d'y pousser
de ce point de vue là les efforts chez
sur la formation des imams pardon je
réponds la cette question monsieur
rachète me paraît une très bonne main
des initiatives du gouvernement mais
paraît intéressante de pousser les
musulmans à la formation des imams
l'inscription dans la loi d'une
négligence de deux de
professionnalisation poserai la question
le problème suivant c'est que la loi
viendrait pour le coup organiser un
culte quand même avec avec le risque de
3 2 avec le risque d'aller dans un sens
peut-être pour l'achipel celui que l'on
a dans certains pays où les imams sont
des fonctionnaires de l'état mais il ne
s'agit pas de faire cela
donc personnellement je voudrais
encourager et quand dans mes rencontres
j'encourage autant que je le peux nous
nos concitoyens musulmans à s'organiser
comme nous l'avons fait c'est à dire sur
la base associative organisé des
universités des facultés enfin des
centres de formation les faire en lien
avec les universités françaises comme on
est tout à fait capable de le faire
aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il était question d'un de former
les imams ses instrus catholique de
paris qui le premier s'était proposé et
avait rendu ce service que l'université
française n'est pas voulu prendre dans
un premier temps là je pense qu'on a des
moyens de ce genre je répugne rêvons à
part à tout ce qui donnerait
l'impression que l'état voudrait
organiser ou fonctionnarisé les
[Musique]
les ministres du culte musulman ou
donner un statut du ministre du culte
comme si l'état avait à connaître de
cela parce qu on retomberait
inévitablement dans une sorte de 20 dans
un genre de concours d'assimiler dans un
régime concordataire
il n'y a pas de statut du prêtre en
france l'état ne sais pas nous sommes
des citoyens comme les autres et nous
exerçons notre activité sur la base des
ressources que nous sommes capables de
mobiliser qu'on est capable de mobiliser
de manière manière paisible dans notre
pays
en essayant de contribuer au bien commun
de notre de notre pays merci il reste
une dernière question qui est monsieur
de bellelay qui a demandé la parole je
vais rationnés merci monsieur le
président aurait donc de répondre puis
ensuite tous les vents la séance pour
accueillir les suivants monsieur merci
président monseigneur mais ma question
était identique à celle d'andré
reichardt mais je voudrais quand même
revenir sur sur un point l'état
illégitime pour prévenir endiguer punir
les troubles à l'ordre public
très bien et s'agissant des religions il
est légitime pour amoindrir la liberté
de culte mais en l'espèce est ce que ce
qui pose problème ce n'est pas les
religions en france mais les
conséquences de l'inorganisation d'une
religion et finalement l'inorganisation
de l'islam en france instrumentalisée
par quelques fanatiques ou ou extrémiste
pose problème alors de de cet objectif
de contrecarrer l'inorganisation
l'absence de formation des imams et des
problématiques de financement notamment
étrangers la loi le projet de loi qui
nous est proposé
envisage un certain nombre de
dispositifs donc nous à vous nous avez
dit votre insatisfaction la perception
assez assez négatif tentaient leurs
esprits créé stricte ivoire punitive
même si vous n'avez pas utilisé ce mot
de punitif il est légitime que l'état
est une exigence d'organisation et de
structuration de ses interlocuteurs est
ce que finalement ce projet de loi ne
t'a pas à côté de l'objectif
et est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à à une
alternative à ces dispositifs
législatifs peut-être avec une exigence
d'organisation d'un contrôle interne que
l'état exige par la loi une forme
d'organisation
sans revenir sur sur les éléments
relevant du concordat que vous évoquez l
instant est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à
une exigence de de structuration voire
de contrôle interne notamment des
financements par une fédération pourquoi
pas à l'échelon départemental qui puisse
elle même organisation en france où
départementalisée et qui soit en
capacité de d'effectuer le contrôle
interne des financements de l'exigence
de formation et des imams sans avoir en
rendre compte à l'état sur le fond mais
en organisation est ce que vous avez
réfléchi à une alternative en complément
de la charte et de la loi existante qui
effectivement mérite parfois d'être
mieux appliquées merci chers collègues
chez présent
alors je ne perds je ne prétends pas
quand même tout savoir et tout décidé je
ne suis jamais que présent conférence
des évêques de france donc je ne sais
pas chargée d'organiser ni la vie en
france ni encore moins la vie des
musulmans eux mêmes les gouvernements
successifs s'ils sont si sont quand même
atteler et pour le moment il existe un
organisme qui s'appelle le cfcm dont on
sait les fragilités mais qui a quand
même quelques quelques mérites notre
contribution à nous autres cultes en
france est plutôt de ces de prendre au
sérieux l'existence du cfcm c'est notre
interlocuteur aussi et nous nous plions
à 7 à cette règle avait à cette
organisation ce qui permet quand même de
leur je crois quand même coup de
contribuer à le renforcer
elle lui dit des à le légitimer dans
notre notre société c'est un début de
cela je pense que nous avons pu
encourager la question de la charte des
imams qui qui a été obtenu et qui a fait
l'objet de discussions mais qui finit
par 2 2 par être acceptée quand même et
nous pouvons et nous continuerons à
aider de 7,7 de cette manière là nous
nous situons plutôt du côté de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le soft power plutôt
que du côté de nous appartient pas
d'exercer la loi et c'est votre votre
difficile responsabilité mais qui failli
pousser les aider les musulmans de notre
pays à s'organiser c'est bien certain il
ya des raisons bien précises pour
lesquelles ils se sont organisés autour
des associations de 1901 au point de
départ et non pas autour des stations de
1905 et je pense que ça ça peut être
la raison initiale pour laquelle ils ont
privilégié le régime 901 mérite d'être
d'être d'être étudiée d'être examinées
de manière à les encourager à ce régime
de l'association cultuelle qui est
encore une fois un régime beaucoup plus
déjà en lui-même sans toutes les
complications qu'importe cette loi un
régime déjà bien bien encadré bien bien
surveillé qui serait bon de faire vivre
merci merci de jeu propose de lever la
séance pour recevoir effectivement
monsieur de travail
[Musique]